you and I live some in the same
neighborhood we live
I could probably hit your house with a
tennis ball if I was super strong and it
was a tennis ball that drifted but you
live very close yet we never ever spend
any time together no no IIIi don't think
that would work at all okay and how
would it even started be like dating
somebody you know I'm not gonna not
gonna date a guy you know what first of
all it doesn't have to be a date but you
and I could go to a Chili's or a
Cheesecake Factory and we could sit
together and we could talk and you could
get to know me I have no desire to get
some area I've actually been at things
where other people have invited both of
us there and I'm sat with you and I said
you know Larry I'm I'm a delight to be
around you to enjoy my company I don't
think so first of all I think you know
you went to Harvard you're way smarter
than I oh I'm not gonna be friends with
a Harvard guy come on what is he smarter
than the people I'm
dumbest people I know went to Harvard
it's not it's a misconception and what
would I do what would I do with you what
are your hobbies what do you do what are
you talking about I play golf do you
play golf I do not play okay so that's
that's gone we discuss Civil War trivia
huh I like to ride a bike oh my god what
you wouldn't you ride a bike yeah put
that helmet on I have one of those
turn-of-the-century bikes with the giant
front wheel oh that if I'm really cute
do wear that you wear a helmet helmet
yeah I wouldn't be caught dead in one of
those helmets those are so unattractive
I don't I really looking at traffic is
not my goal in life I wear a helmet so I
will be alive and then I have hair put
on the top of the helmet I don't even
know I'm doing it